euh
alors
bonjour distingués délégués
le secrétariat souhaite rappeler aux
membres
les mesures d'atténuation suivantes
qui sont en place pour cette réunion
tous les délégués sont tenus de porter un
couvre-visage en tout temps comme dans les espaces publics
et dans la salle de l'assemblée générale sauf
lorsqu'ils sont directement  s'adressant à la réunion,
tout le personnel doit également porter un
couvre-visage à tout moment
des micros faciaux jetables sont indispensables sont
disponibles si nécessaire
tous les délégués doivent s'abstenir de tout contact direct,
y compris les poignées de main
et autres contacts physiques pendant les
salutations en reconnaissance des
exigences de distance physique
tous les délégués  doivent rester conscients des
précautions de désinfection des mains et de contact kovit-19
tous les mouvements et, si
nécessaire, les
files d'attente nécessitent une distance physique de deux mètres
et les délégués sont priés de minimiser l'
activité active jusqu'à ce qu'ils soient assis dans la
salle de réunion l'
introduction des
déclarations préenregistrées sera faite par les délégations
du
état des sièges  ments prononcés par le
représentant physiquement
présent dans la salle de réunion
seront également effectués depuis les sièges nationaux
avec l'aide des
représentants de la sécurité et de la santé au travail
le président supervisera la
mise en œuvre des
mesures d'atténuation au cours de la
procédure
si à tout moment il apparaît  que les
directives ne sont pas strictement
respectées
le président n'aura d'autre choix que d'
attirer les délégués traditionnels à ces
directives
ou même de suspendre ou de renvoyer la réunion au
besoin
merci
bonjour à tous la huitième
réunion plénière de l'assemblée générale
est ouverte
je  maintenant donnez la parole au
distingué représentant du
niger
pour introduire une allocution du chef de l'
état
madame la présidente
étrangère
merci beaucoup
et riche
[Musique]
de vous fournir
muhammad
le travail exemplaire
plus de solidarité plus de
sécurité notamment
appréciation
et il détient la présidence ce mois-
ci c'est e  La dernière fois
ces élections seront un moment décisif
et les pays consolidés
[Musique]
s'assurent que la
mon souhait était de voir ça
ça a été enfin le village
euh
[Musique]
est
le
et plus fort
reflète à travers le monde
les réalités d'aujourd'hui  monde
pour s'attaquer au social
pour l'
éphémère
[Musique]
mon appel pour un vaccin
éradiqué en afrique
féliciter les soldats soldats
combattant en première ligne
dans la guerre contre les convoités
[Musique]
j'ai aussi proposé
est
particulièrement nécessaire
moratoire pandémique coordonné
nouvelles idées
le siècle mondial
la fin de l'esclavage l'émancipation lucifer
le suffrage universel
ont aussi été pensés comme tel un président
pour répondre aux
10 à 10 millions de jeunes qui
arrivent chaque année sur le marché de l'emploi le
développement la croissance et le développement
étaient très présents en ce début d'année 2020
.grâce des
progrès avaient été faits
et beaucoup de nos pays vont se
retrouver ce n'est pas à
lafayette
600 milliards de dollars à  atteindre les ODD
certainement ce chiffre augmentera
la pandémie si nous renforçons nos
partenariats bilatéraux
c'est
[Musique]
communauté internationale
pour le financement durable du
terrorisme
c'est
[Musique]
euh
solidarité vers euh
conclusion alors
que nous cherchons une solution
euh
envoyé spécial pour la liberté
ailleurs dans  le monde la situation la
situation est en
syrie myanmar afghanistan
étranger
accepté la
résolution
palestinienne
i
est
durable et inclusive
[Musique]
et sur
la
mise en œuvre mondiale
[Musique] a
frappé un monde déjà détruit
très peu d'institutions multinationales
pays
que
notre capacité collective à résoudre grâce
[Musique]
qui
la défense des libertés le contrôle contre la
pauvreté
ou les épidémies telles sont les
priorités c'est le multilatéral le
système multinational mondial
au-delà des institutions
une économie respectueuse des êtres humains
pour les nations unies pour nous de réfléchir
nous pouvons rendre l'onu plus habile
[Musique]
il y aura  être plus
efficace
de la famo
merci beaucoup pour votre aimable
attention
au nom de l'assemblée générale je tiens
à remercier le président de la république
du
niger pour la déclaration qui vient d'être faite
je donne maintenant la parole au
distingué représentant
de la côte d'ivoire pour introduire une allocution
par le chef de l'état
[musique] le
président
madame la présidente
déclaration de son excellence le président
de la république de cote d'ivoire merci
excellence votre excellence et monsieur vulcain
assemblée
[musique]
étranger
la gravité de la situation
monsieur le président votre excellence oui
sur
nous'  J'ai vu
l'économie mondiale presque à l'
arrêt les
pays sont maintenant recroquevillés derrière
leurs frontières
avec des conséquences tragiques
étrangères
pour soutenir le président a
permis
grâce notamment à l'
étranger
en fournissant un soutien et une assistance d'
environ 1,5 milliard
notre secteur de la santé la
mise en œuvre de la couverture de l'univers
est
de montrer  est plus
particulièrement
en ma capacité de
servir le pour plusieurs pays africains
à  soulageons sévèrement notre reprise
les affaires
étrangères ont
connu
un mécanisme
réduit à néant
le pib positif étranger
et répétez
[Musique]
comme le gouvernement
le seigneur
sur le front économique et les assistants
pour les pays en développement devraient être
engagés
et mieux mais cela ne nous montre
pas parmi  ceux-ci
et
parce qu'ils sont de nature mondiale et que leurs
conséquences sont des
rivalités et des compétitions nuisibles
je
[Musique] la
paix
étrangère
[Musique]
tout ce que
je souhaite